[Music]
I think it's really important for
parents to realize that the majority of
kids are going to experiment with drugs
and alcohol typically marijuana and
alcohol long before you would like them
to do not freak out if this happens
because the vast majority of them are
not going to have a problem and although
a lot of people would say oh get them
into treatment etc the problem is that
our treatment centers put the marijuana
users in with a heroin and cocaine users
and this is not where you're basically
taking your kid out of a bad peer group
and putting them into a you know for
lack of a better word worse peer group
and this is not what you want to do if
your kid doesn't actually have a problem
so you want to be very careful with
anybody who's telling you to do
something extreme like get your kid
kidnapped or you know and there are
wilderness programs and emotional growth
emotional growth boarding schools and
all kinds of tough love places that
actually do a lot of harm to kids and
parents so unfortunately because of the
bad nature of our treatment system it's
not like you can oh just in case you
could end up doing harm by trying to
help and that is a real issue but what I
would say for parents is that the real
risk factors for kids to have serious
drug problems are having a mental
illness
having a history of severe trauma and
having some kind of outline temperament
so if your kid is especially impossible
has ADHD or you know is adopted and was
in a horrible orphanage for their first
years of life these are going to raise
their risk and what parents can do most
importantly is do as much as they can to
make kids feel loved comfortable and
safe and that's not always easy with
teenagers but and it doesn't always you
know there's lots of wonderful parents
who have addicted kids but if the kid
feel
safe to come to you if they run into a
problem that is what you want in terms
of that's the best thing you can have in
terms of prevention because and one of
the other things I say you know to kids
is if you shouldn't try things but if
you do try something and it's the best
thing ever that is a warning sign that
means do not dive in headfirst and go
for it because that is where the
problems develop there's a lot of people
the people who don't have addiction
problems they get exposed to a drug
that's like the best thing ever and they
say oh my god I better not do this again
because this could ruin my life and this
is why addiction is such a complicated
problem because you would think that
overwhelming pleasure would just take
over everybody but most people have
meaningful lives that they don't want to
lose and that they don't want to ruin
and when they see a sort of instant list
experience it says well you know they
say whoa like this you know I better not
mess with this I could just lose myself
in this so unfortunately that is the
response of the majority of people and
also fortunately most people do not find
most drugs even opiates overwhelmingly
for ik the response is hugely varied in
relation to your genes and to the set
and setting in which you take the drugs
and all kinds of other things so it's
it's really important to recognize that
this is a developmental thing and you
know the truth is that in your teens and
in your early 20s is when you are at
highest risk and the other advice I
always like to give parents is to be
honest and to tell you know try to get
kids to delay as long as possible
just like you would do with sex probably
you know you want because you know their
brains are growing and the more time
they have to develop other coping skills
and the more time they have to sort of
complete the development of their
prefrontal cortex on the less likely
they will be to get into trouble because
if you don't
develop an addiction by your mid-20s
like 90% of all addictions occur you
know and start in that time if you don't
do that your odds of getting addicted
are like single digits it's really low
[Music]